and I was here watching you I was like
who is this guy and how is he so
comfortable comfortable on stage yeah I
get that a lot I get that a lot man you
know it's just you know it's just like
this this is our job training you know
you've got them you got to hit the open
mikes you got to hit the stages you know
different nights man you know and just
work on your craft man you know that's
the only way you're gonna be advanced
it's just like a job man you got to
continue to work you know build a
relationship with the crowd and and just
continue to pause you're set man you
know and it just paying that for me get
out of there you want to watch yeah you
be on the couch Tobias Oh baby this is
it right here we go get your water too
man that's your hot breath water no it's
cool that you're on this let me give you
a proper intro okay hot breath averse
welcome back to another hopper episode
here this is hot breath podcast to a
weekly guide to comedy mastery I am your
host comedian Joel Byers and today we
have a master but he wasn't always a
master he paid his dues this is what we
call in the comedy game a triple og
started comedy back in 1995 uptown
comedy corner right here in Atlanta got
a standing ovation his first time ever
since has been on Comedy Central
Kevin Hart special HBO but they'll also
play golf with a little guy named Barack
Obama but in the meantime this guy has
been on the grind staying in rooms with
Mike Epps that their manager found as
being out in open mikes and seeing Steve
Harvey and deal Hughley and said the
inner
this guy is a master of this craft who
like he just ended his show with he's
next and that's why he's on here because
we believe it as well so if you do enjoy
this episode be sure to just reach out
to him on social media let him know it
was very valuable be sure to connect
with us subscribe to this support us
share this with other comics and that
being said jayjay from the sip welcome
to the hot breath reverse madman finally
finally and job man I got to get your
props man you did your homework already
you yeah you knew that my first time was
yeah man me and my kelp set up men
together a living room actually it was a
literally living room it wasn't any
department man we were staying with a
guy that was managing us at the time
yeah early in my career huh and we live
together in New York man and yet we
grind and gather in their thing man so
yeah so you really did your homework man
this that do your work appreciate how
did how long in your career was that you
stand in there stand in New York um I
see I started in 95 man so maybe about
99 okay 1999 I moved to New York for a
couple of months we had this guy that
was uh and you know know working with us
and everything this way before Mike
people even knew who Mike else was a man
so we did a lot of grinding together man
what do you know what is that grind man
what like what conversations are you
having with Mike Epps your four years in
you guys are sharing a living room well
you know Mike started before me man so
he gave me a lot of pointers about you
know hustling and and hitting different
spots working on your craft I'm getting
out of the south and trying you know
jokes out in different regions because
you don't want to be a regional comic
you want to be able to entertain and
appeal to everybody across the world and
everything so you like Mahmood new york
you know this is where a real big grind
is man you know it's a lot of work up
here man you do two or three shows you
know night yeah you know you may not
make but a total of 125 or 130 but it's
gonna help you polish your show help you
polish your stage time
a lot of great stage presence and
everything man so Mikey ups taught me a
lot early in my career how did you
connect with him so early on uh early on
man you know I'm like you know me doing
stand-up man you know I had a nice
little buzz about my show and everything
man it's a word that's spreaded and you
know we bump we bumped into each other
at a comedy night the five five nine o
an ATL yeah yeah and that verifier Bruce
Bruce and that was one of the toughest
crowd ever heard you met yeah you make
it and the headlining you got to do but
five minutes and just how tough it was
you know if you could get the crowd for
five minutes man that's what that's what
I wore special because they you know
they date teacher span is so so limited
and everything man so you damn [ __ ]
star with your punch line right being go
back and tell you how you set up their
their things so elta great that was a
great moment man and then I moved to New
York like I said man we just started
doing a lot of different grinds together
man so he helped me polish my game a lot
and you also got to see people early on
it I think the buku buku right so that
happened man I was at school Alcorn
State University in long Mississippi on
a trumpet scholarship by the way yeah
they pay for my college tuition but I
just needed a break
so I stopped school for a while moved to
Dallas Texas and start working at Sears
man in the dispatcher that automotive
department staying with my brother and
everything man they used to have this
spot called VUCA ray that Steve Harvey
hosted back in the day man so I mean
this before I even thought about being
standing up coming in man doing stand-up
comedy so I saw a lot of Legends that
VUCA raised from Steve Harvey to see to
TK Kirkland to Lenny from good times DL
Hughley you know just a lot of legendary
comedians man and you know the above
just went off like man that's what I
want to do I think this was my calling
lived in Dallas for a while man going to
watch Steve Harvey destroy people and
greyhounds until my like I said and this
before I mean he had a name but he
wasn't where he is now right and
everything man so that was that was a
great opportunity to go out and and just
check out different comedians that we
all loved today and then and then and
appreciate and everything that's what
you hear in this game is like in the old
days you hear like earthquake at uptown
like just they're almost like the
foundation yeah cracking there yes clap
making people laugh yeah absolutely
absolutely so once I started doing
stand-up man I did Uptown my very first
night Cory Zhu Miller was a very old and
they're trying to get him on here oh
yeah yeah that's a very first person
they ever brought me onstage and I'm at
a toy store like my very first night I
did open mic night pack Tuesday night
uptown the old uptown that was in yeah
yeah yeah uptown uptown coming the
corner that was in Buckhead right behind
Hugh she's upstairs and the plaster the
og uptown man it was a Tuesday night
you know packed they had legendary
coming sit in the audience at the time
cuz they did open mic then they brought
the the big names up so you had DC
courier in the audience you had Chris
Charles hey earthquake you had zoom and
chocolate our names Jay was in the
artist Chris Tucker was in the audience
so they do open mic and man everybody
was bombing mmm everybody was bombing I
was kind of like last on the list and
everything man and so zoo man he was
like man we're not gonna I'm gonna do
one mo open mic and then we're gonna go
to the headline I mean to the pros and
the crowd was going crazy but then like
the next open mic wasn't me it was
somebody before me so I was gonna I was
getting ready to get bumped so I stopped
sue I stopped crew I stopped zoom and I
told him man my name is Jay Jay I'm on
the list he said brother man I mean I
really need to go on stage tonight cuz
if I don't go up tonight I might not
come back you know I just I'm nervous
ready I think I had my show was ready
you know everything man I guess he felt
it and saw it in my eyes he said man I'm
gonna do one more I'm gonna let you go
up and he whispers in my in my ear said
man you got to rock this thing could the
crowd getting antsy they want to see the
folks that that's in here so zoo was
Kurisu Miller went on stage he said man
I'm gonna do one more open mic you know
how to cry be late I don't want to see
nobody we don't know in their thing so
zoo was like man this dude made me
believe and feel like we need to put him
on stage and zoo gave me that
opportunity so I went on stage and my
first line on stage I'll never forget it
I told the crowd say I know y'all could
see it in my face
you probably can hear it in my voice but
I'm nervous as hell crowd gave me they
clapped gave me the motivation
everything did well standing ovation my
very first night would you close with
Ike or I had this joke that I talked
about the difference between white
colors bands and black colors bands okay
so I usually cuz I was in the band at
Alcorn of course played the trumpet so I
went to a historical black university so
I was in the band sore
I was wondering one that was be jamming
on in the end and the band and
everything man so I used to do the
difference between them you know the
white schools and the black schools and
got a standing ovation man I stayed with
it Here I am today I always ask comics
on here one of their epic booze stories
or one of their epic bombs like what is
one you've had in your mind
epic bomb definitely came from the five
I definitely came for the five nine nine
and Mike Epps was the host that night oh
my elbows the hoax that particular night
cuz Bruce was on the road doing some
things man and man that crowd let me
have it let me have i'ma just I just
went ready right all right I just be
real I just wasn't ready at that
particular moment but I told him I said
you know I'm not scared of y'all I'm
coming back yeah I'm coming back so I
came back probably the next two Tuesdays
and and and rocked and everything man
you know it was that was a real tough
crowd man
like man if I can make it here at five
five nine I should be able to you know
perform in in front of anybody I think
that's an important note for comics too
is like you opened up your first show
with like hey here's the reality I'm
nervous that's that established like ya
nations with the crowd in there they'll
establish a connection because they felt
like you were one of them and everything
man so they they appreciate my honesty
they let me let them know that I'm
nervous I'm nervous my voice is cracking
but I'm here I'm here to try to
entertain young man and I did well that
particular night man and luckily
earthquakes saw me earthquake kept
bringing me back let me host you know
some some show yeah during the weekends
just just kept giving me a chance to
polish my show and everything and I
never forget earthquake used to always
bravely on stage why the crowd was
coming in he started to show before even
people were sitting down and I never
understood it at first I never
understood it I used to always say man
maybe earthquake don't like me maybe
earthquake don't know he don't really
care for me to be on stage and
everything man but one time can you know
can't past alone he let me realize he
like man this is just a wave me showing
you know the you that this is a way you
won't have to you know entertain the
crowd you never know you got a baby in
town entertaining crowd why are they
coming in my folks are ordinary drinks
and their food when they not paying
attention at the time so you know it
just helped me get my moustache presence
in Miami in my establish my you know my
known just my style onstage and
everything so you know it panned out I
get it now
understanding yeah your your comfort
onstage remember the first time I saw
you you were hosting like a Mari Sims
show here in Atlanta okay and I was here
watching you I was like who is this guy
and how is he so comfortable comfortable
on stage yeah I get that a lot I get
that a lot man you know it's just you
know it's just like this is our job
training you know you got them you got
to hit the open mikes you got to hit the
stages
you know different nights man you know
and just work on your craft man you know
that's the only way you gonna be in
advance just like your job man you got
to continue to work you know build a
relationship with the crowd and and just
continue to pause you're set man you
know and it just panned out for me yeah
gives your connection with the crowd I
would say is what's been a driver for
you to not only host for like said but
you've hosted festivals and yes tours
absolutely absolutely it's what what
tips do you have for comedians on how
they can connect with the audience I
mean probably just I've been I basically
just tell them the same thing that I did
you know just continue to get on stage
man work on your craft work on your time
and working on your stage presence I
mean just continue to know where the
microphone is you know I mean it could
be a karaoke it can be I mean I port
your night or anything wherever my keys
man just get on stage and try to you
know get the crowd to a know enjoy what
you were doing bring them into your
world and then establish show you know
your craft that way so the more
connected your you are to your material
maybe the more connected the audience
will be absolutely because I try to I
try to I try to give the crowd something
to where they could actually paint the
picture of what I'm talking about you
know how you know like in cartoons or
magazine cartoon magazine or something
like that they got the little cloud and
they got the little words in there and
you know they paint pictures that's I
try to visualize myself when I'm telling
my jokes I'm trying to get the crowd to
visualize and understand what I'm saying
when when I'm saying and they see it
once I get them to see what I'm saying
you know they're they're in tune to what
I'm doing and then Joe might cry out
that way I noticed that watching you
tonight right if we want to go into a
specific story the story of you playing
golf with Obama yes absolutely and I did
notice just in several stories you were
saying I was like I am seeing this yeah
I'm seeing what you're talking talking
about yeah how do you know just no years
of practice right yeah grinding years of
preparation man you know just you know
just trying to
establishing you know my craft and bring
them into my world so when you're saying
like a younger comic maybe like oh I
went and played golf with Barack Obama
and then they're like and they make a
joke about his swing or something right
you tell this story that's true and
almost like step by step right what is
the secret or what is the the structure
of storytelling to where you can just be
like this has happening and this would
happen next and that's what happened
after that is it like details what is
what do you make sure I know if this
details I mean you know I try to talk
about real-life experiences like that
was a real life experience so you know
just there being in that moment of being
around Barack Obama man you know even
though I wasn't trying to write a joke
about him at that particular time but I
was really in tune of the fact that how
we was interacting with one another and
and talking and watching his mannerisms
on the golf course and watching watching
him talking cuss when he made a bad shot
god but trust me he was out there
cussing you thought that cussing bankers
you know golf you know golf make you
getting mad quick think so you know man
and then I just brought the experience
on stage and you know I worked it out
like I said it wasn't really trying to
be a joke and everything now just
letting people know man what it was an
honor to play without 44th President and
it just happened to end up being funny
so you started out developing that story
by just going on stage going on stage
that's the only way you especially for
me I think for all coming man you know
you can write out your joke all you want
and you can try the owl in them in the
mirror at home all you want but until
you get on that stage I have that mic in
front of you that's the only way you
want Babel to work out you got to work
out the kinks you gotta see what goes
where should I put this right here now
I'm putting I'm gonna take this out put
it up front then put this front part up
here you know just keep juggling it you
know you know once you do a joke man you
may do it at one time that particular
night man but it still not
no and it's potential still keep working
it out man keep still working it out
keep still working it out until you just
get a flow that you feel that's
comfortable enough for you that make the
crowd visualize what you're doing a flow
that's interesting yeah you say it a
flow there's almost like a rhythm to the
way and so it's a rittle rhythm
especially for me you know every timing
is different right and so it's a it's a
flow it's a rhythm for me you know I
don't just go up there and just say I'm
gonna do this right here I'm gonna do
this right here I'm gonna do this right
here cuz I mean once you get on that
stage you got that Mike and Mike got
them like song you got all those eyes on
you know some things may change you know
every crowd is different every crowd is
different every situation is gonna be
different I mean you have some crowds
man they come in to laugh and listen and
ready to be entertained and you have
some crowds that may you don't have
issues and problems and they've not
ready to laugh or they may be talking
through your set and everything and that
could possibly throw you off so you know
every crime gonna be different every
show is gonna be different man you know
you just it's just all about the time
and the reps that you do on stage yeah
your pace onstage as well in terms of
like how methodical are with just how
you're talking is there is there
something to like the silence because as
a comedian
you know I've you know I'm a little over
nine years in okay I'm just now starting
to like hear the silence and I'm like oh
you can use the side yeah you could use
the side of you yeah lean into it you
can use the silence because I mean once
I can say once you got that you feel
like you got the crowd in tune and what
you're doing that meant for me that
makes you feel like they in your world
they open it up they're in their minds
and and and and everything where they
want to just listen and and picture what
you're talking about so you don't have
to be I used when I first went on stage
yeah when I first started that's all you
want you just want to punch them in the
mouth and then you know good night
but now you know I'm I'm season I've got
a lot of years into the game man so now
I know how to flow I know how to you
know no scratches joke out take my time
and you know just be patient and
and just let it ride that's what I
noticed yeah patience yeah yeah so what
may tell one story of like I met brocco
bomb and it's like two minutes but you
can turn that two minutes six seven
minutes quicker like my intro the song
that I do in the intro man all right
Sheila man you know it's amazing I never
thought that was just go the way it is I
mean it went viral I've been doing it
for a lot of for a few years now you
know you know how some folks be like man
I don't want to hear that joke no mo but
man I can't get rid of it
oh man they get mad at me Joey when I
doing a B let me why you do the bass
guitar man and people keep telling me
even veteran coming like man can never
get rid of that wow that's one of the
coldest opening intros of all time
that's what I mean that's what I get all
the time people be like man you've got
the coldest intro one that one of the
coldest intro they say to me and JB
Smoove may have the top intros of all
time I don't know what JB Smoove intro
was back in the day but they say he had
a killer intro as well and people just
love me for that man even people that
was out there man tonight they're like
man you please do the bass guitar joke
man and you know what man didn't like I
said that's that joke went so viral that
the people like the rapper's like 8-ball
MJG and Taylor they found them like tila
the song it really is it was it Stila
featuring a bomb MJG man they Tila hit
me on and on on Instagram or something
laughs man heard you rocking my soul
across the world you like I appreciated
so man you know how I met them I met
Jazze PHA who who produces they came up
with the beat I met the guy
finally got a chance to meet the guy
that actually did the bass I like I met
the whole circle from you know who made
the song man so it's just amazing how
viral that that that song went for me
and that song is so old
yeah it's so hip
yeah go people after you after my shows
folks to hit me on my own instagramming
some like man was the name but that song
you need okay just come out
that's mid nineties easily and that just
come off you did you just randomly do it
one not just and randomly did it at
uptown when DJ can't love no yeah we're
at love you know and love is the master
on that on the turntable and and man we
just rocked that thing and it hit so
well here today here it is a day man and
you can call it back and I can call it
back anytime
the DJ's be ready I mean DJ they're
there they'll get so into it and feel it
they'll even do it inside of my set when
I don't even ask for it but it goes deaf
so perfectly it's just a go there cuz
they get the fear they know where they
will possibly hit I'll be late man yeah
I liked it I wanna add it right up in
there so yeah man if they went it went
viral and sometimes you can see it
comedian and be like oh they're doing
music cues yeah yours like fit fit some
people is that they have you got those
comics man that that do music all in
between they set you and if the DJ ain't
on point
they'll kill a whole show it will kill a
whole show so thank God I'm not one of
those man where I just need constantly
music no nothing like that I do it at
the beginning I do it at the beginning
and you know and entertain the crowd
like that without to that I'm straight
into material and just try to come up
with some things off the dome the first
show flew by watching you and oh yeah
just yeah just flows over hey I like I
just got up here they gave him the light
already but that's just how in tune I
was and what I was doing the crowd was
into him and they seemed like they had a
great time
it's is it I don't know because I hadn't
seen you in a couple years I knew you
were always been one of my favorites and
I saw you again I had to come back and
be like dude you almost ruined comedy I
was like man
you're going to coming yeah what are
some tips you have for chameleons out
here on the grind that it's like part of
the process like things you learned the
hard way there onstage or off like what
are some tips that you always go to for
common man for coming I mean when folks
are coming women will come to me for
advice because now the the exposure is
not like it used to be you know Def Jam
as window down Beatty coming view has
truly winded down some man so we don't
have those outlets of putting your
material on TV like they used to like I
was blessed I talked like the last tale
of Def Jam back in the day and the last
look Taylor coming view but I was able
to establish myself in front of
comedians that was already established
and they helped me you know Ricky
smiling took me on the road plenty of
times early in my career earthquake
helped me polish and gave me that that
that that beasts into the coming again
because I was his opening next so I got
a chance to just sit and watch and in
take in how he rocks a show and his
stage presence and how he flows in into
the crowd had a raucous show oh man when
I say raucous show I mean he just he hit
you in your side oh yeah yeah just
relentless he don't give you a chance to
breathe or none like that man so he
taught me how to be that that that
gorilla on stage okay and then I was
lucky enough man after the Kings a
comedy tour ended everybody did they
look separate thing and went individual
and their thing I was blessed to do some
shows and said your entertainers
hometown st. Louis Missouri and its
management team came to a couple of
shows that I did at small venues and
they enjoy me and they pulled me to the
side like a man you're funny dude
I want you to come work with Cedric the
Entertainer I'm like word wow so that
was a beautiful you know experience
right there and you know I did at least
12 years with Cedric oh yeah being its
opening act man
and he taught me a lot about the
business you know yeah you know how to
know how to be smooth on stage how to
appeal to everybody every junior every
age how to flow how to be smooth on
stage then he taught me how to interview
how to negotiate your contract your
dealing your you know meeting and having
means and what to talk about and what to
ask what type of questions the acts so
he said help me go to another level
because he gave me a chance to entertain
do my show in front of his crowd and
build my brand in that way how do you
negotiate I mean it just depends you
know who you're talking to what you're
trying to negotiate man you know you
just try to stay firm okay no you tell
them what you would your what your ideas
and your plan is whether your goals are
set to be to being this business and
everything man and you know and y'all
both just try to you know be smoothing
and just come from here and in their way
so it's important on the business side
if you want to deal in business first
have a clear vision on what you want
yeah absolutely you got to have a vision
of what you trying to do in this
business man cuz everybody path is so
different like I say I've been doing
standing up 24 years you know it's some
time some time it may take a person
eight nine years and sometime it may
take a person 20 years
a prime example was Bernie Mac Bernie
Mac had been doing stand-up since the
70s yeah I mean but he didn't really get
this breaking - pretty much you know Def
Jam we knew who he was and but then when
the Kings economy came around he took it
to a whole nother level and then he got
his show you know cuz his style was
different
everybody was scared to get here my
opportunity so you know you know the
same way with me you know I'm I'm very
southern I have a very strong southern
accent and people recognize that but
they love it
it's different there's not a lot of
people doing it and everything man so
everybody loved my servant Wayne so I
think that's gonna truly be AAA outlet
for me to take my career
to another level did you find when you
started out in comedy you weren't as
southern on stage and as you got more
comfortable you kind of became more into
your so I came into my true voice I came
into my own I was able to be comfortable
enough to show people who I am in my
background and what I stand for and just
believe in my just believe in you know
what I was doing and be like hey I'm
gonna I'm not gonna change y'all I'm
gonna make ya'll change in love me for
what I do you know everybody everybody
jump shot ain't like Kevin Durant mm-hmm
but damn is you know Russell Brett
Westbrook shot might be ugly but it
works for ya know so everybody everybody
passed it's different everybody style is
different you know you just gotta find
your own lane and and and just staying
there man and just pray that you don't
see you know dead ends or no outlets
that's that's gonna hold or hinder you
back all right well I think I hear your
feature onstage baby said we're gonna
we're gonna wrap this up okay before we
get out of here is there anything else
you want the world to know man just make
sure you follow your boy listen out for
me I'm JJ from the seal one of the
best-kept secret understanding of comedy
backs man make sure you follow me JJ
from the silk on Instagram and Twitter
comedian Jay Jay Williamson is on
Facebook my website is I am Jay Jay
Wilson
dot-com and just look out for my trust
me I being a city near you real soon and
I tell you what could you do a hot
breath favor and look into the camera
let them know your name and why they
comics should listen to the hot breath
podcast I'm JJ wimps and aka Jay Jay
from this silk and you need to check out
hot Rev podcast because this is one of
the coldest podcasts in the country not
just in the south not just in the ATL
one of the dopest and you got one of the
dopest hosts of this park had my man Joe
by man I appreciate you having me man
I always been a fan with you man you
know we'll see each other a lot man I
love them watch you work as well man I
appreciate it
absolutely absolutely thank you man very
much
[Music]